what does your portfolio look like right
now i know uh you were kind of all
bitcoin then you went bitcoin and ether
uh what does that look like today so we
just understand the perspective you're
coming from
um my current allocation
is probably 70 percent
eth 5 bitcoin
and then a tale of
others
so why that allocation there's nothing
against bitcoin it's not against
anything else it's because i'm a
financial markets guy and we use risk
curves
so at certain points in the cycle in the
middle of a bull market you want to take
as much risk as possible so you want to
go to the
more speculative end of the market
so
firstly you know i isolated the fact
that i thought ethereum was going to see
further flows it's early in its adoption
cycle and that would probably drive
prices further than bitcoin and that
seems to be playing out
with the others there's so much going on
it's difficult to monitor so i i have
kind of basically a relatively
broad-based portfolio to capture some of
that move when the tail goes up by the
furthest risk out and that happens in
credit markets equity markets all over
the place in equity markets in a in a
bull market you tend to get the big
leaders first which is where the safe
money is the blue chips then eventually
people move to emerging markets and then
they move to frontier markets and it's
in order to get more bang for your buck
in the middle of the cycle and generate
some alpha so it's not a
it's not a comment per se on my
relative view on the success of
protocols or something like bitcoin it's
nothing to do with that it's about how
do i
make money
out of this crypto investment whilst
maintaining my my um level of interest
in the overall crypto world and so
that's where i am now where would it be
in a year's time maybe it's much more
bitcoin again so it's just that it's an
asset allocation strategy to try and
enhance rewards so this is really
fascinating because i think that uh
using the legacy market as uh a mirror
if you will to the crypto market is i
think uh what people can kind of wrap
their head around and you're talking
about these cycles of kind of bull and
bear markets and so if you were uh
allocated to bitcoin in 2017 being in
2017 it went up 20 x 1 000 to 20 000
other assets went up more than 20 x uh
but then in the bear market bitcoin drew
down the least right most assets went
down 90 95 99 bitcoin went down about 80
85
and so it feels like the blue chips
those kind of larger market cap assets
uh they have less volatility both up and
down whereas the long tail uh has much
more of that volatility they're just
smaller less dollars to actually move
them it's kind of what you're talking
about here when you think about us now
in a bear uh bull market makes sense why
you're allocated the way you are will
you then look to kind of consolidate
into the large caps in
a bear market if you think that's where
we're headed or do you yeah or like how
do you think about the transition i'm
trying to get my head around this
and i'm thinking that
yes i will move down the risk curve back
to the the safer assets where i think
there's less volatility you can use you
know some yield from stable coins or
staking or whatever to lower your
volatility and then you want to be
looking to buy the speculative end of
the market that's going to get destroyed
whether it's parts of the nft space or
parts of the kind of general token space
that gets destroyed in the next bear
market to buy those when they're heavily
discounted but they still have network
adoption effects or some perceived value
or cash flow
that becomes really interesting because
then you can start allocating in the
middle of a bear market into the riskier
assets to buy them super cheap and
that's typical of credit markets um and
equity markets people always do the same
and that's where you get the alpha from
is getting this asset allocation right
and very few people do it because
they're they're still a little bit
blink into one project and the idea is
you can believe the whole space goes up
you can even have total belief in one
project but it's a long time to get
there so
is your allocation waited correctly for
you to reduce the volatility a bit so
you can sleep at night in the bad times
and get a bit of extra out performance
in the good times